à l'airé
angie
tut tut nyala paul royer
c'est devenu son quotidien baignade et
marche sur une plage isolée quelque part
dans le nord du brésil
avant de pousser la porte de sa future
maison
ian
savoy jazz il te de bons derniers photo
b
capucine diriger une agence bancaire à
paris et ou
alors le voilà c'est un peu gros et je
le cherche c'est un peu voilà ça on se
cherche tous les jours
liane son mari était cadre dans
l'informatique ils construisent
aujourd'hui l'hôtel de leurs rêves une
pousada brésilienne c'est un petit peu
vous pour vous et moi
[Rires]
avec leurs deux ados ils ont tout quitté
pour ce bout du monde
c'est petit à toutes les choses sont
arrivées mes enfants que vous êtes
fatigué
oui alors c'est un de choses comme ça
que vous voulez qu'ils ont fait par jour
on y va
une envie de vivre loin des villes de
retrouver du calme et de la sérénité
comme capucine et gagnent de plus en
plus de français plaque tout pour
changer de vie certains d'entre eux
choisi de se réinventer au bout du monde
amélie etienne peu sont ingénieurs ils
vont devenir agriculteur et vont vivre
seul sur l'île de quéménès dans le
finistère pendant neuf ans
nouveaux décors nouveaux métiers mais
pas le droit à l'échec c'est ce qui les
fera vivre désormais
à les aventuriers on va dire
enfin d'autres choisissent le soleil et
la mer à perte de vue aux maldives 50 de
français se sont acheté une île pour la
protéger des promoteurs
une vie au paradis car si vite ici
depuis six mois elle a quitté paris et
son travail pour reprendre l'activité
hôtelière de lille
bienvenue versez 1 chanter bonjour
ils vont vivre loin de tout
un choix radical est pas si facile au
quotidien
pendant près d'un an nous avons suivi
les aventures de ce héros bas-fonds du
21e siècle
[Musique]
ah ben là c'est juste le paradis c'est
juste le plus bel endroit au monde donc
y revenir ça fait toujours un petit truc
spécial va forcément au
'cela fait vingt ans que christian vient
ici il ya même le jem un atoll des
maldives nommé reavie
beau
il arrive de france pour l'accueillir
des amis devenus copropriétaires de cet
archipel il ya aussi cathy sa femme elle
vit ici depuis six mois
tout comme jean marc présente gm general
manager
donc voilà
donc grâce à lui arrivé lui aussi en
forme et la directrice du la directrice
du concept l'acadie voilà ça c'est
l'équipe de choc à jacques derrière
l'équipe de choc il y à cinquante deux
actionnaires dont certains sont ici pour
quelques jours et toi quand on te voit
ça fait quoi une semaine que tu es là
ensemble ils ont investi un million six
cent quatre-vingt mille euros le prix
pour acheter 50 % des parts de sept-îles
et de son petit hôtel une quinzaine de
bungalows
question n'a pas quitté son travail à
paris il fait donc des allers retours
donc là je suis en situation illégale
parce que j'ai des chaussures évidemment
arriver ni on n'a pas de chaussures
c'est no news le shoes c'est la base de
révéler
pourquoi parce que c'est plus sympa
c'est plus convivial il n'y a pas de
route ya pas de voiture il ya que du
sable blanc tout fin et donc c'est
tellement facile et tellement agréable
que pendant une semaine on met aucune
chaussure
depuis 20 ans christian passe toutes ses
vacances ici il connaît tous les
employés
vous est pas présenté momo il faut que
je vous présente mon mot avec ses ça
donc momo c'est un petit peu grâce à lui
que le projet a débuté donc c'était je
crois le 13 août de l'année dernière
donc en 2017 je reçois un petit message
de moments qui me dit
qu'à thiès que tout va bien je lui dis
oui et une pose la question est ce que
tu veut racheter et venir et puis je dis
mais pourquoi tu me dis ça et il me dit
ben
voilà arrivés lieta ventre parce qu'il a
dû voir des investisseurs qui venaient
visiter l'île et moi je suis allé voir
christian dans son bureau
jeudi à christian christian s qui aurait
pas quelque chose à faire pour sauver
rivelli et puis voilà
sauvés rivelli c'était empêcher qu'un
grand complexe touristique s'installe
sur l'île et la dénaturent pour ce
projet cathy a tout lâché elle
travaillait à la française des jeux et
s'occuper des gagnants aujourd'hui elle
a fait le pari de relancer l'activité
touristique de la petite île des boules
de pétanque
sarah fait partie des cinquante deux
actionnaires elle vient d'arriver de
bordeaux le fait de préserver quelque
chose
qui enfin un projet qui a du sens
préservation à la fin de l'environnement
et puis on est dans l'état d'esprit quoi
avec avec toute l'équipe qui est sur
place et qui clôturait cette île depuis
d'années pour certains dans le star donc
oui c'est ça qui m'a séduit d'avoir
quelque chose qui a du sens épique et
qui est palpable on va tout à l'heure où
il n'oublie pas intubé tenue maldivienne
alors
voilà ça tombe bien vous allez inaugurer
les nouvelles bull
quelle chance voilà un extraordinaire si
on va on va attaquer sa
up
regardez comme c'est pau je ne suis pas
blasé et je suis venu donc avant de
faire partie du projet est de venir ici
en tant que directrice du concept je ne
me suis jamais assez de ce paysage qui
est différent tous les jours c'est
magnifique et je m'extasie à chaque fois
de la beauté des lieux
avant le début de la saison haute à noël
cathy et son équipe test auprès de
quelques touristes leur capacité à
animer ce petit paradis préservé
des petits bungalows style simple pas de
climatisation pas de piscine pas de
constructions sur pilotis
rivelli est l'un des rares à tall encore
authentique des maldives et c'est cela
que les actionnaires veulent préserver
allez on y va
attention
2-1 asie
tiers 10 secondes de pénalité la
aaa gens je peux sans te sens faible
arles un peu
[Applaudissements]
en plus de villes principales
les français ont aussi deux petits îlots
cet après-midi cathy doite inauguré sur
l'île du soleil levant un nouvel endroit
où les vacanciers pourront déjeuner
c'est à la nage qu'elle s'y rend
[Applaudissements]
sur notre compte mais ça devant
et là on peut
j'espère qu'il va prochainement faire
jackson donc on se dit qu'effectivement
comme avait conditionné la 10 place et
[Applaudissements]
on a préféré rendre à 7,6 qu'en fait son
côté vraiment naturel c'est pour ça qu'à
la construction allait totalement
naturelle selon quand vous venez dans la
journée vous êtes tout seul ou en
profiter et donc cette construction on
peut manger à plusieurs c'est aussi
cette référence à quelque part à
robinson
mais une ombre plane sur ce tableau
idyllique
les français partagent la concession et
la gestion de rivelli avec un partenaire
local et les désaccords se multiplient
ils l'attendent dans les prochains jours
une rencontre décisive pour l'avenir de
leur île
l'avenir d'amélie etienne lui s'est joué
il y a quelques mois lorsqu'ils ont
postulé pour devenir les locataires du
nil
pendant neuf ans etienne toulouse en
bleu
tu manipules et j'ai
fait le choix de quitter votre maison
corps non c'est un grand changement
c'est sûr que parfois on a des petits
coups de stress à se dire ce que tout va
fonctionner est-ce qu'on va y arriver
mais bon d'autres l'ont fait avant nous
puis si on prend les choses une à une ça
fait le dernier sec
j'espère que ça à faire
[Musique]
donc ils sont là
talent et et du bateau
non il est pas mal
trois heures de route depuis saint
brieuc à travers la bretagne pour
rejoindre le petit port du conquet
ils ont investi leurs économies pour
acheter ce bateau et puis ce qui va
désormais les nourrir et les faire vivre
des plants d'oignons et de pommes de
terre à ça sent l'oignon c'est bon signe
car sur l'île il n'y a rien
fish est en train de faire des noeuds
ouais super
allez c'est pas grave et par batifoler
si on va candidater c'est qu'en fait on
avait quand même le côté aussi revenir à
des choses simples jusqu'à les sur sur
la nature les saisons là pour le coup on
est on est complètement indépendant
démarré avec lui dans le même rythme que
de ce que t'as faim tu es sûr continent
et que les têtes un travail de l'autre
c'est différent
à 20 minutes de bateau
[Musique]
ces cabinets c'est l'heure où à laquelle
et ménez au large du finistère
un caillou balayé par les vents
un kilomètre 6 de nos 400 de large le
conservatoire du littoral leur a confié
la mission d'entretenir lille en échange
ils paient un loyer modeste à peine 600
euros par mois pour leurs maisons des
chambres d'hôtes qu'ils pourront louis
et des champs à perte de vue
c'est là désormais qu'ils vont vivre
rien que tous les deux
[Applaudissements]
vous voilà
ou est-ce qu'on est là on est dans la
cuisine de la maison d'hôtes donc c'est
ici qu'on va préparer pour les tous les
repas qui seront pris avec les visiteurs
sur l'île c'est clair et net qu'il faut
faut toujours tout anticipé
quand on aura dix autres avec nous
faudra quand même
bien bien prévoir les choses parce que
là il s'agit quand même d'assurer
les précédents locataires était resté
dix ans
amélie etienne était ingénieur ils sont
en train de devenir agriculteur à
l'ancienne
aux plantes du mieux qu'on peut et on
croise les doigts pour que ça pousse
ils serviront à leurs hôtes ce qu'ils
cultivent mais il leur faudra aussi
vendre sur le continent leur production
pour en tirer des revenus
une dernière petite faction
[Applaudissements]
du bateau
forcément
ça
bon c'est pas terrible
on la sent c'est super mais s'arrête pas
des plus efficaces causant la pomme de
terre devant l'onu
[Musique]
attends je vais le prendre
etait-ce ufo
qui choisit mais je dis moi j'ai
l'impression de faire un petit
point
il faut autre chose
l'idée c'est de pouvoir mettre en valeur
et protégé
va avoir sur la ferme en fête
parce que là pour l'instant les pommes
de terre c'est pas les nôtres on les a
plantés aujourd'hui alors on les mange
pas le même jour comme on tient le bon
bout et des pommes de terre mais la ruby
il reste la moitié men ha l'année cteur
avec dumont auteur avec les autres déjà
2 d'avril à octobre on aura un des
personnes autour de nous repas du midi
et du soir bon moment vu le comment les
journées sont remplies en plus le soir
oui
et parmi ces d'alès coucher mais je
trouve que la crème est trop floue il
leur reste un mois pour tout préparer
avant l'arrivée des premiers touristes
de l'été
de france pour arriver ici il faut
prendre un avion jusqu à fortaleza puis
rouler deux heures le long de la mer
pour atteindre par à-coups rond
je
une petite ville aux bords des dunes
loin de tout
mais m
[Musique]
c'est pourtant ici que se sont installés
capucine et yann il y a quelques mois
c'est pas le poisson dire
me donner un gros morceau vous pouvez me
découper sa enfilé 20 kilos et demi
comme ça ça me paraît bien ça dure au
balo c'est l'équivalent du bar c'est
vraiment pas cher c'est un reais le kilo
c'est super super poisson pour un prix
vraiment dérisoire ça fait
5 euros
[Musique]
je me suis pas encore habitué
sincèrement la présentation des poissons
sur marché
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jamais été malade en jeu
tout va bien
le poisson a une image du concert
lorsqu'il n'est pas dans de la glace etc
et des mouches c'est qu'il était prêt
grand prince on verra jamais de l'art
est présenté comme ça
ce changement de vie yann et capucine
l'ont préparé pendant deux heures
presque un petit peu ici
moi je suis là jusqu'à lundi
le marché il est jusqu'à lundi après il
y aura plus rien rezaï est fermé
il parle très très bien parti gay
franchement très bien
marie-jeanne accent très fort
we want you
il a dit oui j'ai parlé le premier choix
j'aime bien je pense
on a appris comment avant de partir on a
pris des cours le dimanche matin la
maison en réponse à paris la honte à lui
en a pris
quelques quelques mois de cours un les
dimanches mais sera présenté dans le
bain c'est difficile
ok ou est obligatoire
ils ont découvert par à kourou lors d'un
voyage un vrai coup de coeur
ils y sont revenus trois fois avant
d'acheter un terrain vague un an plus
tard ils en sont là à la tête d'une
équipe de dix ouvriers brésilien mais
les travaux ont déjà pris trois mois de
retard
c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça je trouve
qu'est ce qui vous met à
mal non non franchement rien un petit
bobo c'est tout on va continuer
ils veulent couvrir dans six mois au
plus tard mais il reste encore beaucoup
à faire
mais je comprends mais quand il y aura
de l'eau ça fera comment
on est d'accord vous allez mettre tout
on
reste toute la partie écrite la
couverture on le toit un pour être clair
le toit il reste les terrasses à imposer
parce que chaque chambre entre terrasse
en bois ils sont petits balcons son
petit hamac et cetera le jardin tous les
chemins d'accès chaque chambre donc la
décoration intérieure de chaque chambre
nous on a un budget
financiers bien précis et qui mène
jusqu'à justement version prévue au mois
d'octobre novembre dernier carré après
ça va être compliqué puisqu'on a
effectivement deux enfants et la côte
difficulté c'est quand on n'a pas
d'argent on peut pas finir de payer si
c'est pas fini si on peut pas payer
l'école des enfants peut pas mourir
voilà après il ya plein de charges
électricité la vie on a beaucoup investi
en a beaucoup ici on a travaillé plus de
vingt ans donc oui on a cassé avec la
carrière par les tirs lien en tout cas
c'est tout tout retard était pour
pouvoir avancer dans ce projet là parce
qu'à un moment donné poisson il faut
prendre des risques la mairie sur
l'appli un bien même
on va donc là ce matin farley le
français c'est le seul bâtiment qu'ils
ont achevée c'est leur maison pour
offrir un cadre de vie agréable à leurs
enfants car eux aussi ont tous quitté
leurs amis leur école et chaque matin
c'est avec leurs parents qu'ils font
classe et là on aurait démarré ce matin
sur la maman avec clarisse 13 ans en
classe de cinquième
on y va parce qu'après il va falloir
relever tous les timbres seller et
gagnent avec pierre en seconde et donc
ça ça doit être égale à o car est aussi
en finlande sur deux défaites voilà donc
les cris et les issues
être
s'abriter
légal non moins égal à égal c'est
également un gazon le lieu de l'action
ça se passe on
ajouté mais bon c'était pas moi
je veux croire qu'elle intelligente j'ai
des fois y'a des choses elle croit que
l'intelligence
je pense qu'on n'a pas mesuré finalement
la charge de travail au quotidien c'est
pas facile c'est pas facile de se
transformer finalement maman en
professeur même pour les enfants
je pense que clarisse parfois je
l'énervent
très souvent voit là parce que je dois
jouer le rôle de professeur et j'oublie
totalement la carte de maman il ya des
tensions c'est pas toujours facile
la protectrice r ça c'est clair
[Musique]
l'après-midi le frère et la soeur
rejoignent leur école brésilienne en
uniforme
c'est le moment pour yann et capucine de
découvrir les activités qu'ils vont
proposer à leurs clients
aujourd'hui ils vont tester la balade à
cheval dans les environs
[Applaudissements]
c'est notamment si on a des clients est
ce qu'on peut venir ici pour
comment on dit déjà commencé proposés
soient inclus
fallait il pour faire un tour de cheval
avec nos clients vous avez combien de
chou comme ça on sait combien de qui on
peut prévoir vous nous donnez prix par
personne
[Musique]
je comprends je comprends ce que je vous
propose d'abord on fait un tour comme ça
vous comprendrez mieux ok on voit ça
valait
pas bien
bon ça va
joli point de vue judiciaire
quand est-ce qu'on descend du
singe est en tout cas pas les bahamas
en avant en avant chouchou
imaginez
totalement
sèche et r non c'est magnifique mais là
quand on arrive en haut de la dune la
hausse juste sublime parce qu'à la mer
juste en bas c'est sur
un moment pour se dire qu'ils ont fait
le bon choix dans quelques mois il
espère revenir ici avec leurs premiers
clients
[Musique]
aux maldives la journée de cathy
commence toujours par une séance de yoga
sous votre corps se sent bien et reposer
[Musique]
les on se relève une relaxation
bienvenus
car depuis quelques temps les choses ne
se passent pas comme prévu pour l'équipe
de river
à trois semaines du début de la saison
tous les bagues à l'eau ne sont pas
encore prêts
il ya plus de quatre jeunes du tout
le personnel de l'hôtel est mobilisés
mais ce n'est pas assez
elle wade aille où tu as assez de kachan
pour faire
ok après celui là je n'aurai plus assez
ok tu pense qu'on pourra terminer
aujourd'hui
oui pas de problème pas même
ses treize personnes et ces personnes là
quand on les mobilise aujourd'hui c'est
des personnes qui sont divisés sur
d'autres activités les armes il ya des
cuisiniers
gens qui s'occupent de la technique donc
urgent que dans tous les départements
aujourd'hui pour faire ces travaux là
donc on est en train d'essayer de
réfléchir avec notre partenaire apprécié
de de renforcer justement le nombre de
travailleurs qu'on a assuré livres pour
essayer d'accélérer ses travaux et
pouvoir démarrer d'autres problèmes
les français n'ont que 50 % de la
concession ils doivent donc composer
avec leur partenaire local
et celui ci ne veut pas embaucher de
personnel supplémentaire mais katy a
réussi à le convaincre de venir sur
l'île pour qu'ils se rendent compte des
besoins
il est attendu comme le messie ce jour
là
[Applaudissements]
c'est aussi le jour de l'anniversaire de
stefanik l'une des cinquante deux
associés
cloud 1 cathy s'éclipse une mauvaise
nouvelle vient de tomber
leurs partenaires ne viendra pas
il n'y aura pas de réunion aujourd'hui
la raison tant attendu ne sera pas là
on est bien
christ mais ça veut dire que ça va être
encore compliqué pendant un moment ça
veut dire que j'ai encore recevoir des
messages qui vont être très difficiles
surtout jean marc
ça veut dire aussi que moi j'ai part à
paris dans quatre jours écoute on en
vint un jour je ne serais pas là
mais du coup on n'y a pas d'avancé par
rapport à toutes les difficultés qu'on
rencontre
il s'est bloqué
l'associé maldivien refuse de collaborer
et sans son soutien le projet est
menacée
j'espère qu'ils vont pas arriver sous
bada vie labrune ta bulle cl
ça va là pour l'instant et encore tous
mes
h - 3
pour le moment ça va mais quand je vais
voir que le temps a passé
et que les plats seront pas forcément
tous prix peut-être que ça va un peu
monté mais ils seront prêts peuvent
aller
sur l'île de quéménès aussi l'avenir est
encore incertain
allez c'est parti c'est un grand jour
pour amélie etienne l'arrivée de leur
premier hôte trois mois après leur
installation
mais revêt lé petit bijou de quéménès
les rubis de quéménès ça c'est une
variété rouge à pont rouge
qui est excellente en pommes de terre
sautées
mais voilà le marché est fait
ils attendent un couple venu de belgique
jusqu'ici
ça fonctionne bien ça
c'est les tout derniers préparatifs ben
oui un dernier
dernier contrôle de la chambre
histoire que
que ce soit
presque parfait
voilà c'est bon
les arrivants oui
tout santé
etc si tu es heureux un patient
c'est quand même un moment assez
important quoi joue
t nadine et jean jacques kimpe
2004 non mais c'est pas grave parce qu'à
20 minutes le four étanche aux flammes
mais et après je retrouverai juste pour
fignoler cg pas fini les boissons
oh ça va ils vont parler dans le
brouillard tout
il ya une petite vous montrons mais
c'est pas
et picabia
cabinet jean jacques et professeurs des
scream
nadine sa compagne historienne de l'art
ils sont venus chercher ici le calme et
la simplicité
ils ne vont pas être déçus
[Musique]
voilà votre chambre vous avez vu la sur
le phare des pieds-noirs
d'accord dont tu as une éthique
une petite illustration la voilà ici
vous avez la réserve de syrte où elle
est sèche surtout surtout
n'hésitez pas en être comme ça ça évite
les odeurs c'est important
énergie solaire et une économie d'eau
vous en mettez par les gars d'à côté
venir chez amélie et etienne c'est
presque un acte militant ce que l'on
vous suggère c'est qu'on vous met au
défi
le défi trois minutes tr min pour la
douche on vous invite à à mettre lolo du
début dans se bat et comme ça ben non on
ne perd rien parce que l'on est
précieuse
c'est super
mais péter
quand j'ai commencé
à
tête gi oh oui oui
[Musique]
à table amélie et étienne partagent le
repas avec leurs hôtes et leur histoire
la première fois qu'il la raconte avant
lui d'autres sans doute
24 octobre à la fin de l'entretien on
leur dit bombe à sous quelle échéance
devrions avoir une réponse de votre part
sous une dizaine de jours bon ok et le
lendemain midi non emails lis mais
c'était c'est elle qui est si on était
toujours partant la cité nous qui avions
étaient reclus
et là j'ai pleuré peut-être que deux
restaurants guy collet ils ont tout de
suite compris quand ils vous tapez
compris que la
fédé pour faire de l'île de quéménès
effectivement
si le pari de l'activité hôtelière
semble réussie reste celui de
l'agriculture
j'ai un peu mal au ventre
amélie cn ont livré leurs premières
récoltes deux semaines auparavant ils
attendent des retours
faut penser qu'elles ont plus longtemps
que tu as des chances à rien
[Musique]
j'espère
bonjour police et pauline
collins et un méli de l'île de quéménès
ça vas y toi
depuis
m mais pauline je me permets de
t'appeler pour prendre des nouvelles
étant donné que
bonnes
c'est cool
ouais
atop
amélie de la ferme de l'île de quéménès
je me permets d'appeler pour prendre des
nouvelles de ce que l'on a pu vous
livrer il ya une petite quinzaine de
jours maintenant
non
donc 10 kg de rugby 20 kg nicholas
56 le csac ben 6 6 1 c'est pour ça qu'on
anticipe et 10 kg de supplément
oui
à técou la wii la clientèle a bien bien
réagi la pomme de terre est elle est là
maintenant c'est ce qu'on va faire
nocturne
ça va les journées sont longues mon
métier me prépare toi
etienne
et nous freine 52 chaque
film à dire mais est-ce que vous allez
pouvoir approvisionner parce qu'il
n'avait pas encore donner le chiffre est
il dit est ce que vous allez pouvoir
approvisionner pour utiliser doit
toujours c'est pour ça qu'on anticipe et
me dit bah ouais 52 chaque
cool
on va dire que c'est une récompense du
travail qu'on a fournis jusque là et qui
nous encourage aussi pour la suite voilà
un
bon
[Musique]
200 kg de pommes de terre a livré au
plus vite
amélie etienne ne s'attendait pas à un
tel succès pas si vite ils vont se
mettre au travail rapidement
nadine n'hésitera pas à mettre les mains
dans la terre
jean-jacques lui aussi apportera son
soutien à sa façon dans quelques jours
amélie doit présenter sa pomme de terre
à un chef étoilé comme l'ultime
reconnaissance
[Musique]
au brésil aussi les choses avant cet
enfant la famille peut souffler leur
terrain ne ressemble plus à un
interminable chantier
un peu comme mon livre on tourne les
pages vient de finir un chat people au
chapitre de la piscine c'est fini enfin
safran avance
un nom et demi après leur arrivée
capucine savoure sa nouvelle vie
un plaisir quotidien je dirais même un
jour besoin d'avoir les mains dans la
dans la terre dans l'eau on mais planté
voir grandir les voir pousser c'était
sûr plaisir c'est un plaisir simple
c'est bien agréable
c'est mon nouveau bureau voilà j'ai pas
d'ordinateur j'ai pas de siège est pas
un écran j'ai pas tous âgés mais j'ai
des fleurs
s'il améliore et quidonnent paulo dow a
favor
aie aie aie
[Applaudissements]
elle a bon dos brigade
pas grand chose en fait où j'aurais pu
avoir le temps mais je le prenais pas
et j'avais surtout pas l'idée de
préparer des jugements pour mes enfants
je pense que j'avais plus le temps de
m'énerver sur les devoirs qui était pas
été fait j'étais plus énervés fatigués
sur plein de choses qui voilà qui
n'allait pas mais je prenais pas de
plaisir et c'est aussi pour ça que l'on
a changé de vie je prenais pas le
plaisir de
de prendre le temps en fait pour faire
plaisir à mes enfants un moment donné
nous
me faire plaisir aussi
[Musique]
yann aussi prend du temps pour lui dès
qu'il le peut il se rend sur une autre
plage à quelques kilomètres de part à
coudre
au coeur de la nature c'est vraiment
servent en france génial record aussi sa
vraie nature je pense en tant qu'être
humain
c'est le plaisir de
de se retrouver soi-même
il s'est mis au kitesurf la spécialité
de la région
venir ici ne pas faire de kite c'est un
peu comme habiter à la montagne n'est
pas faire de randonnée ou pas faire de
ski c'est un peu dommage il ya des gens
qui traversent la planète pour venir
faire du kite ici
dans quelques semaines leurs premiers
clients arrivent et la décoration n'est
pas terminée comme souvent aussi les
délais sont aléatoires
un banal phocéen
c'est pas des casernes c'est comment ce
charmant comment on dit déjà massenya
temps
ça saigne à ding dong ding comment ça
marche
c'est ma grande joie nous avaient dit
qu'ils connaissent un monsieur qui
faisait des cloches dans deux portes
d'entrée et donc fait il n'a pas vu
monsieur c'est pas tête ça c'est
toujours comme ça
ils ont hâte aussi de sortir de leur
tête à tête
ouais ça c'est bien ça fait un très
grand comme ça
présentement
eux qui ne se voyaient que le soir et le
week end en france passent désormais
beaucoup de temps ensemble
diamètre
à qui s'était déjà m et bah à mesma par
hacker condos vos cd ces événements sont
annoncés ce que je suis là condos
[Musique]
coupez
où je suis bénie bhl non mais laisse
faut lui expliquer déjà compliqué
ça y est
longtemps
c'est trop grosse comme ça va descendre
tu voyais ça descend progressivement
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile d'être
collègues de travail quand on est un
couple aussi
parfois oui pourquoi
non parce qu'on n'a pas forcément les
mêmes goûts les mêmes idées les mêmes
envies au même moment etc etc mais bon
c'est comme dans la
c'est comme dans la vie
vie professionnelle c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué quand on
travaille comme ça en famille
votre saga direct sinon on un peu plus
on a fait qu'on a un peu plus direct
mais ça se passe bien après
de retour à la maison une bonne surprise
des attentes enfin le bois qu'ils
espéraient depuis plusieurs semaines est
arrivé
à tant d'égards
est tombé
ce bois il ay là il a parcouru des
milliers de kilomètres entre le sa coupe
dans le para et puis sa fabrication ici
il a fallu le sécher il a fallu le cas
on voit bien il est vraiment propre
super bien sur terre bien poncet c'est
très très joli très juste c'est un bois
de très belle qualité en france on fait
plus des choses comme ça à quasiment ça
c'est important de la chance des
toilettes et ça ça va être la porte un
peu plus large la porte d'entrée on
repart j'aime bien
ça qui sont mentionnés moi c'est pour
vous c'est de voir son projet qui avance
voir les choses qui rentrent pour que
les promesses finalement disparaître
tenu aussi parce qu'on a attendu à tant
de jours
on a beau démarrage constante
leur pousada prend forme reste à
attendre l'avis des premiers clients
hacker ménès les premiers hôtes d'amélie
et étienne achèvent leur séjour
et il semble conquis jean-jacques laisse
quelques souvenirs
salut les faits et nadine accompagne
amélie elles vont rendre visite aux
nouvelles habitantes de lille mais
regardez qui arrivent là ça c'est mort
fait sur ses caramels je reconnais pas
la touche sur la tête
des brebis
elles sont arrivées quelques jours plus
tôt elle aussi sont chargés d'entretenir
quéménès en broutant l'herbe
c'est pas trop dur de quéménès
si si c'est dur
le plus dur que ce que je croyais ce
n'est qu'un au revoir
à mes filles sont en droit thierry magie
ce côté inhabitée juste
[Musique]
cepess silence
ce super du bien
vas-y je t'en prie le refermer la porte
derrière nous une porte ultra sécurisé
merci quand vous portez vous vers un pas
trop travailler avec merci en tout cas
et bon retour à vous et bonne
bonne fille témoin
atrocités bien
c'est passé libre bah oui
purée
dax était hier qu'on est allé chercher
de nouveaux seule amélie etienne
s'apprête à faire une session de travail
nocturne demain il faut livrer les 200
kg de pommes de terre
savait qu'on allait payer beaucoup ne
pèse pas sur un ampli basse saxe et les
débuts donc on a encore besoin de
s'organiser de la de caler les choses là
faut dernière par exemple j'ai créé la
maquette de nos étiquettes de cagettes
en qualité
après un bon massage
non non ce soir on se couche pas si
darcos
le lendemain après une courte nuit
deux tenues pour aller livrer les pommes
de terre
ils partent livry plusieurs magasins du
continent
et surtout un chef étoilé très intéressé
3 4 5 et mais les convives
[Musique]
au port du conquet ils retrouvent leur
camionnette
pour rejoindre brest à 30 km
le chef étoilé philippe le bigot les
attentes
ouais c'est ça sert
on lui a livré à quinze jours des
voitures un petit échantillonnage de nos
pommes de terre et pour le coup cette
semaine quand on l'a rappelé il nous a
commandé des pommes de terre pour les
cuisiner
c'est je vais
c'est pour les garder au frais
on a mis la salle à grenaille ouais ok
ça va bien pour moi oui ça veut bien
heureusement je me situe à
la rue bidon
plus costaud celle ci on a mis de la
moyenne soit 1 c'est bien aussi voilà
après je vais faire ddd qu'il rondelle
que je vais que je vais jouer mais que
je vais rajouter sur mes plans fait
d'accord imposer une pomme de terre
bassin dans le polar ils ont un très bon
goût en fait c'est surtout la saveur
si un produit un petit peu assez
original d'où il vient quand même même
si la pomme de terre est bien connu
l origine 12 de sept-îles et dit ça
vient c'est ça fait exceptionnel elles
vont passer entre les mains de badauds
de personnes enfin
passionnés
et
sera compétent doit l'avouer ça et donc
ouais c'est un honneur fille bête qu'on
peut prendre une photo ensemble oui avec
les pros contre j'ai pas ça des petits
tâche ne va pas voir tu sais ma part
il y a un an à peine ils passaient leurs
journées derrière leur ordinateur
ils ont aujourd'hui gagné leurs galons
de cultivateurs
mais pas le temps de s'attarder un
groupe de dix voyageurs est attendu sur
l'hymne
aux maldives après des mois de tension
une solution semble se profiler
christian revient de malé la capitale où
il a rencontré leur partenaire local
celui ci est d'accord pour céder une
partie de ses parts j'ai pas laissé le
choix je dis qu'on pourrait pas
travailler dans ces conditions c'est
trop compliqué avec en bonus 50 50 ça
marche le 50/50 ça marche pas pour pour
vous 2 c'est bien parce que sur les
recrutements ça a bien avancé sur tout
ce que vous vouliez mettre en place donc
c'est mieux que ce qu'on a vécu depuis
depuis deux mois
pas de temps à perdre les touristes sont
au rendez vous pour les vacances de fin
d'année et vivre loin de tout comporte
une contrainte majeure
il n'y a rien sur 10 jean marc est
chargée de l'approvisionnement
une tonne de nourriture environ arrivent
chaque semaine par bateau
le défi c'est d'abord
tout ce qu on souhaite avoir à ce moment
là à la veille du jour de l'an
le réveillon une soirée test grandeur
nature pour l'équipe de river
et c'est cathy qui est en charge de
l'organisation de cette première grande
soirée sur l'île
finally
we je pense qu'on peut être ici le bar
basso pas bien physiquement je tiens
cette garder la pêche
c'est évidemment pas facile surtout un
jour comme ça surtout avec les enjeux
mais une bonne énergie
il ya une bonne équipe ont fait ça quand
même avec beaucoup de beaucoup de gaieté
et celles qui aident à tenir
c'est quoi mais oui s'il peut on s'en
sortira
plus que quelques heures pour
métamorphoser la plage et accueillir une
centaine d'invités
au brésil
avec six mois de retard les travaux sont
quasiment finis
les contres
et ce soir le premier client arrive
plus des bonis lemaitre le poney
[Musique]
c'est vrai je suis comme fort
non
eh ben il faut s'entraîner puis je pense
que c'est un coup de main à prend 6
voilà les femmes qui font ça les hommes
qui font ça toute la journée ils ont
justement un mot on n'a pas encore fini
on démarre alors ce qu'on va faire c'est
vérifié la changement parce que je pense
que le client arrive il était là la
deezer scène originaire en bas qui est
bientôt prêt et ça la change va finir m
après
qu'est ce que tu dis si tout va bien
[Musique]
il ya des choses on sait qu'on devra
améliorer puis j'espère que globalement
la note sera plutôt la donne sera plutôt
plutôt bonne
mais y aura des trucs à améliorer c'est
qu'il sera pas parfait
je pense que globalement ça dort et
amant
du plus près d'eux
permet en fait
la pression juste avant l'arrivée du
client
il s'est bien passé gillet français il
vite au brésil depuis plusieurs années
combien d'heures
très bien taris ma fille a effacé ce que
j'avais
très jolie encore pas mal de choses à
faire à finir mais bon
on en voit le bout quand même on en voit
le bout ça et c'était très très loin
très presque deux ans maintenant mais le
savant deux ans
qui commence mais justement vous allez
être
si aujourd'hui vous risquez d'être déçu
parce que on va donner le maximum
[Rires]
après deux années au brésil
clarisse se sont plus à l'aise en
portugais camp français
merci beaucoup
si vous faut voir ce soir on dit ça y
est composée là si vous avez besoin je
ne sais pas d'autre chose que ça marche
trop mignon cas est ce qu'elle est c'est
un petit mot premier client à 2 heures
gilles je suis tellement content de tout
ça est magnifique et je suis très fier
d'avoir aidé mes parents la préparer
[Musique]
la nuit est tombée le temps est venu de
souffler et de recevoir leurs premiers
hôtes comme à la maison
[Musique]
et fatigué un peu moi je pratique go et
enfin enfin du stress qu'il aurait aussi
elle est fatiguée parce que m'a quand
même pas mal aidé
un
match qui a dit beaucoup quand même
énormément aidé mais le vrai parce qu'on
romains ont clarisse mais d'affaires les
peintures clarisse a fait les peintures
sur les murs les rouges les vert et bleu
lézard fait avec moi qui sait les
chaises elle a fait les chaises qui sont
sur le terrain cela fait les résines
avec maman elle a fait nettoyer passé la
somme ira dans le lait corps à sion
décoration les rideaux les troubles
érectiles et moralement ainsi
pour fêter l'ouverture de leur hôtel ils
recevront dans quelques jours tous les
gens qu'ils ont rencontrés depuis leur
arrivée au brésil et qui les ont aidés
à quéménès la fin de saison approche le
gîte s'est remplie
c'est un choix qu est tellement atypique
ouais ça inspire ça fait voyager seul
homme des idées
on a l'impression d'être allé loin
[Musique]
soyons généreux 300cc la cuisine de
quéménès
juive c'est un peu le dernier pâté de
pommes de terre de la semaine c'est non
seulement comme et oui
jean non parce que là jamais des lardons
mais je veux finir le la version sans la
cuisine et nos produits c'est c'est
encore plus gratifiant tu as tu as tout
ça prend sens quoi bein c'est vachement
c'est cohérent c'est cohérent on est
avant tout agriculteur et pour le coup
bien les fruits de notre travail
derrière
on ne fait pas que le vendre en direct
là pour le coup on cuisine est on est on
le donne à goûter en direct c'est top
[Musique]
heureux de leur nouvelle vie amélie
etienne n'ont pas vu l'année passée il
déborde de projets pour la saison
prochaine on est parti
[Musique]
à
au brésil il ya des capucines ont
présenté à leurs amis le résultat de
deux années de chantier
et tous son compte y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aller gachassin pour tout le monde
[Musique]
aux maldives la fête bat son plein
au bout du monde l'année 2018 s'achève
en beauté
six failles font la lumière
bonne année à tous merci encore d'être
là
l'incitation aux magnifiques maillots
ils ont choisi de vastes espaces pour
mieux se réinventer vivre comme des
robinsons des temps modernes
il ne compte pas devenir des ermites
bien au contraire ils veulent t'offrir
partager leur aventure hors du commun